[MUSIC PLAYING]
SPEAKER 1: If you're
running online retail,
your business depends on
more than just the products
you offer.
You also need to know
how they're selling
and how you compare
to your competition.
With Google Market Insights, we
can help you make the most out
of your data and get
insights that you
can use to fuel your growth.
Getting started
with Market Insights
is easy and only
takes two steps.
First, enable Market Insights
through Merchant Center.
And second, set up the
BigQuery Data Transfer Service.
This won't change how you're
using Merchant Center to list
and manage your product data.
You'll now have access to new
data specifically provided
to help you see
a bigger picture,
such as seeing how your
prices compare with others
and being able to discover
the top-selling products
and brands.
Let's see what insights can
help you grow your business
by better understanding how
your products are performing,
how they're priced, and which
products you should consider
adding to your assortment.
We'll start by looking at the
overview of your products.
To understand how your
products are doing,
you need a top-line view
of your entire feed.
Drilling down into your
offers by brand and category
lets you check in
on what's popular
and what may need
your attention.
In addition, it's
important to keep up
to date with any
technical or policy issues
that prevent items
from being listed.
Once you have a better sense
of the health of your feed,
you can better understand
how to price products.
There's a lot to factor in
for pricing, including how
your prices compare to others.
Price benchmarks
help you quickly
see where your prices sit
against your competition
and suggest actions
you can take.
Consider letting your customers
know about your competitively
priced offerings
and think about ways
to adjust your pricing for
products above the benchmark.
But what about the products
you're not carrying?
With the best
sellers report, you
can keep an eye on
the market and make
sure you're not missing out
on any popular new items,
like which brands are
selling more than others.
This data can also
be used to figure out
what categories you can
carry more products in
and what products you
can carry substitutes
for when there's high demand.
Stay informed in areas where
you can grow your business
and take action.
Then measure how
you're performing all
from a dashboard built from
the Market Insights data.
These insights can
help you understand
the best way to grow.
But your business may also have
additional first-party data.
Once you've set up
the export, the data
is directly accessible
in BigQuery.
From here, you can share the
data directly, build dashboards
with Data Studio, or
integrate with other tools.
For example, take your
Merchant Center data,
automate weekly reports in
business intelligence tools
like Looker and Tableau,
and build a data pipeline
that combines your selling
information with your supply
chain data.
Combine these out-of-the-box
insights with your own data
insights to maximize the
potential for your business.
If you want to get started,
head to the Merchant Center
to enable Market Insights.
Then set up exporting
this data to BigQuery.
Check out the link
onscreen to get set up.
Start using insights to
fuel your growth today.